cette année l'aïd el kébir et yom
kippour tombé quasiment à la même date
mais est ce que vous savez ce que c'est
que l'aïd el kébir et yom kippour est ce
que vous savez ce que les croyants font
précisément à l'aïd el-kébir yom kippour
ou pour une première communion pour
pâques
finalement on sait pas grand chose sur
les religions et pourtant on en entend
beaucoup parler plutôt de façon
anxiogène et et par les crises le
conflit israélo-palestinien pour le
judaïsme l'islam et le terrorisme mais
question du voile le christianisme et la
manif pour tous les questions de
pédophilie sans parler du débat
politique et médiatique et les cantines
le halal
la france pays judéo-chrétien de race
blanche
bref une approche plutôt anxiogène
alors si ça l'est pour vous imaginez
pour les enfants ils vivent dans le même
monde que vous ils sont confrontés aux
mêmes environnements avec les mêmes
questions et ils vont chercher à y
répondre à leur niveau avec leurs
réponses qui sont parfois naïve
pourquoi le monsieur est pris avec un
bonnet de piscine ou moi je sais
pourquoi les bouddhistes ils ont pas de
cheveux en fait ils ont tellement boudé
qu'ils ont perdu tous leurs cheveux
parfois un peu brutal
ah non toi tu peux pas être ratée c'est
pas possible ou choquant
les juifs y sont bien habillés parce
qu'ils sont riches mais ce que vous
apportez vous des connaissances sur ces
sujets pour comprendre un endroit où ça
semblerait logique qu'on le fasse à un
endroit on vous apporte des clés des
connaissances pour comprendre le monde
dans lequel vous évoluez à l'école à
l'école lake pas nécessairement pourtant
l'institution elle-même
à souligner le sujet depuis quelques
années déjà en 1989 le rapport joutard
soulignait la culture religieuse
croissante des collégiens et des lycéens
en 2002 le rapport debré proposé
d'introduire l'enseignement des faits
religieux à l'école
c'est dans les programmes pourtant c'est
peu fait pourquoi soit par opposition de
principe
on a sorti et la religion de l'école
elle a plus rien à y faire soit non pas
une opposition de principe mais une
certaine réticence ou inquiétude à le
faire du fait d'une certaine inculture
religieuse de la peur des enfants des
parents de l'institution qu'est ce que
je peux faire qu'est-ce que je peux pas
faire et finalement aussi par manque de
moyens pour pouvoir l'aborder
alors même que c'est une porte d'entrée
pour aborder et comprendre la laïcité
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a créé
enquête il ya cinq ans pour aborder les
religions le fait religieux par l'ong de
la connaissance et ce au rentrant par le
jeu et les questions que les enfants se
posent au quotidien et avec cette
pédagogie de la maïeutique partir de
leurs questionnements aujourd'hui
enquête c'est 300 enfants qu'ils suivent
des ateliers dans une dizaine de villes
dans le cadre de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires ou des centres sociaux qui se
retrouvent une fois par semaine pendant
10 à 25 séances et ils vont jouer jouer
autour de ces sujets avec des jeux qu'on
a décliné des jeux classiques des jeux
de memory des jeux de quiz des jeux de
tabou des jus de vrais faux et on parle
beaucoup dans ses ateliers
mais c'est aussi des outils pour les
enseignants et les éducateurs pour
aborder plus facilement ces sujets avec
eux comme par exemple l'arbre a défini
un jeu en cohérence avec les programmes
où les élèves ont faire deviner au reste
de la classe un certain nombre de
notions comprendre la différence entre
arabes et musulmans comprendre
que sait que l'athéisme ce que c'est que
pâques une mosquée où l'étoile de david
on touche à peu près dix mille enfants
parents avec ses outils pour autant une
classe d'âge ses huit cent mille enfants
donc vous comprendrez bien que c'est pas
avec nos petits bras qu'on va y arriver
c'est en donnant les moyens aux
enseignants en les formant pour pouvoir
le faire en les convainquant
c'est possible et pertinent de le faire
l'agrément qu'on a obtenu de l'éducation
nationale en début d'année et les
demandes croissantes qui nous
parviennent nous permettent d'avancer
néanmoins il ya un vrai challenge devant
nous et un vrai challenge pour
convaincre que c'est important que c'est
faisable que c'est pertinent montré que
les objectifs de cette pédagogie montrer
que c'est un outil pour comprendre le
monde dans lequel on évolue en termes de
culture générale en termes
d'organisation de l'environnement fixe
la construction du temps pourquoi est-ce
qu'on est en 2015 et pas en 5776 en 1437
comme dans d'autres religions
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en vacances à
pâques la compréhension de
l'organisation de l'espace
pourquoi est ce que dans une ville comme
paris n station de métro qui s'appelle
trinité où une ville pas très loin qui
s'appelle samedi comprendre les
pratiques sociales des uns et des autres
pourquoi est ce que mon petit copain
mangent pas de porc à la cantine
pourquoi est ce que ma petite copine
s'est rendu dimanche dernier dans un
endroit dynamique du loup sur la tête
d'un bébé donner à comprendre mais aussi
pouvoir parler de ces questions sur un
mode apaisé aborder les différentes
convictions à la fois religieuse et à
religieuse avec respect donner à
comprendre que parler du juif du
musulman de lattes et du chrétien ça a
pas de sens à la fois parce que dans
chacune de ses convictions
il ya différents courants mais aussi
parce qu'à une façon toute particulière
individuelle de se relier à un texte une
pratiquer une spiritualité
il s'agit aussi par ce biais là de
parler de la laïcité de façon
intelligente
non pas de façon anxiogène c'est en
rentrant par les limites les interdits
qu'il faut poser ce qu'il faut mettre en
place pour pas que ça déborde non comme
une notion qui est à revaloriser qui est
à rendre positive mais aussi d'autre
part pour permettre aux enfants de
comprendre ce que c'est que la laïcité
de façon intime non pas comme une bulle
juridique qui le flou très au dessus de
nom qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour moi
si je suis athée et que mon petit copain
il est croyant on serait jamais d'accord
jamais d'accord sur cette chose qui est
essentiel pour moi peut-être qu'ils me
donnent à comprendre le monde
pour autant je pourrai jamais lui
démontrer qu'il a tort je pourrai jamais
lui démontrer que dieu n'existe pas
comme il ne pourra jamais me démontrer
que dieu existe
néanmoins si on est assis l'un à côté de
l'autre
1 il ne me met pas en danger
2 on a des choses à échanger ça peut
être intéressant et troisièmement on a
des choses en commun au delà de ça
comprendre globalement c'est si moi je
veux être respectée dans ce que je crois
il faut que je commence à accorder ce
droit là ce respect la personne qui est
à côté de moi je me suis lancé il ya
cinq ans quand ma fille est revenue de
l'école ravi parce qu'elle était en
vacances de la toussaint
ou très inquiète parce que son petit
copain elias avait mangé du porc par
mégarde à la cantine et qu'il allait
être super malade j'avais pas
nécessairement tous les atouts en mains
ni enseignante ni pédagogue né
universitaire ni spécialiste de ces
questions
néanmoins l'intimé conviction que je
devrai donner des outils à ma fille pour
qu'elle comprenne le monde et qu'elle en
ait pas peur et qu'elle comprenne la
laïcité autrement comme une négation du
religieux non la laïcité comme un
principe républicain
assis sur quatre notion la liberté de
conscience la liberté de culte la
séparation des églises et de l'état et
la non discrimination pour raisons
religieuses
convaincu que je devais donner les
outils à ma fille pour qu'elle comprenne
qu'elle n'ait pas peur qu'elle soit en
mesure de choisir et d'être libre merci